[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
the remembrance of Earth's past Trilogy
is one of the best sets of speculative
science fiction books to appear in
recent years the trilogy explores themes
surrounding both the human will to
survive and the potential of mankind to
inflict harm upon itself rather than
band together in the face of a greater
threat another major theme is our place
in the universe and assumptions about
the cosmos and our lack of actual
concrete knowledge about it because of
its exploration of these themes the
remembrance of Earth's past is one of
the most existentially terrifying series
of the modern era in my opinion I've
covered several aspects of this series
and videos that can be found Linked In
the playlist Below in this video
specifically we will discuss the ending
of the final book in the trilogy Des end
this video will have spoilers for all
three books in the series so keep that
in mind
the star dx3906 had been gifted to
shungzeem during the crisis era by a man
named tiam ning Tian Ming would go on to
be the only human being ever to make
physical contact with the alien beings
known as the trislerans who had
attempted to invade Earth and claim the
planet for their own with the help of
Tian Ming's brain the aliens devised an
attack on humankind lulling humankind
into a false sense of security the alien
strike nearly destroying all of mankind
when the hour has grown late and all
hope seems lost the inhabitants of the
vessels blue space and gravity who had
left the human solar system long before
this time triggered a gravitational wave
transmitter revealing both the location
of Earth and the location of the
Homeworld of the trisolarins as we have
discussed in detail in other videos in
this universe the revelation of one's
location is deadly due to the Hostile
nature of cosmic Society
trisolaris is quickly destroyed and
eventually Earth's Own solar system is
flattened into two Dimensions Xiang Xin
and AA are the only inhabitants of the
solar system to escape by the time they
reach Planet blue hundreds of years have
passed from the perspective of Earth due
to the effects of relativity
and AA find guani fan a former
inhabitant of blue space and gravity on
the world he had only been woken from
hibernation a few years earlier from him
they learned that mankind has expanded
during the years of shangzin and aa's
travel through the vacuum of space I've
also discussed this in detail in past
videos
guanyi fan is ultimately the one who
teaches Shang Xin about death lines
which were left as the result of
curvature propulsion a method of faster
than light travel within a depth line
the speed of light could reach zero
nothing could move within a deathline
after returning to Planet blue after
investigating signals from the other
world in the system Planet gray Guan Yi
Fan and shangzin receive a transmission
from AA down on the surface of Planet
blue she informs them that Tian Ming has
returned
aa's voice was agitated I've called you
multiple times and the ship's AI refused
to wake you I told you we have to
maintain radio silence what happened
young Tian ning is here
Xiang Xin was Thunderstruck the last
traces of sleep left her and even ifans
jaw hung open
and Guan Yi than enter the shuttle to
pile it down to Planet blue but before
they can something goes horribly wrong
Shang Xin experiences then the effects
of being inside of a Time vacuum the
moment seemed to be infinitely short and
infinitely long she got the feeling that
she was outside of time but also
stepping across it in a Time vacuum the
length of time in that moment cannot be
measured because within a Time vacuum
time does not exist
at the same time she felt herself
collapse as though she was going to turn
into a singularity meanwhile the mass of
her guanyi fan and the shuttle
approached infinity and then everything
plunged Into Darkness
the death lines which Sean Zain and
guanyi fan had discovered leading from
planet gray had ruptured seemingly due
to interference from tianming's ship
because of this they expanded to cover
the entire solar system the shuttle and
guanifan ship Hunter were now orbiting
Planet blue at light speed except light
speed in this region was now less than
20 kilometers per second shangzin and
guanyifan were trapped without the
computer systems Hunter and the shuttle
could not decelerate
didn't want to ask what their next step
was knowing that nothing more could be
done no computer could operate when the
speed of light was below 20 kilometers
per second the shuttle's AI and control
systems were all dead under such
conditions not even a light inside the
spacecraft could be turned on it was
just a medal with no electricity or
power
humans at this point in history had
prepared for the potential of drifting
into the trails of light speed ships
this was why both the shuttle and the
larger vessel possessed a secondary
system based on neural computers such
systems were based on the brains of
intelligent animals and could operate in
reduced light speed environments
the key isn't the speed of light but the
system design the transmission of
chemical signals in the brain is even
slower only two or three meters per
second not much faster than us walking
neural computers can still work because
they imitate the highly parallel
processing found in the brains of higher
animals all the chips are designed
specifically to function under reduced
light speed conditions
the neural systems on both the shuttle
and the larger ship would take about 12
days to boot this process was extremely
slow due to the rate of Serial data
transmission under reduced light speed
they both would have to enter a
short-term form of hibernation
they now orbited the planet blue at
light speed and though light speed for
them was reduced within the rupture
depth line time still moved much faster
on the outside can you see the patterns
on the Belt repeating periodically ifan
wasn't looking outside at all his eyes
were half closed as he strapped himself
into the hypergravity seat there
fast try to follow the motion with your
eyes changing tried to match her moving
gaze with the patterns flowing across
the belt for a moment she could see the
blue white and yellow patches they
blurred almost immediately I can't she
said that's all right they're moving too
fast the pattern could be repeating
several hundred times per second Ethan's
side
noticed his sorrow despite his effort to
hide it and she knew why she understood
that every time the pattern repeated on
the broad belt it meant that the shuttle
had completed another orbit around
Planet blue at light speed even at
reduced light speed the Demonic rules of
the theory of special relativity still
held in the planet's frame of reference
time was passing tens of millions of
times faster than in here like blood
seeping out of her heart
it would be 18 million nine hundred and
three thousand 729 years from the
perspective of the outside before they
would again set foot on planet blue
part two the black domain era
shenzin and guani fan awoke from their
hibernation about 16 days later from
their perspective the neural computers
on both the shuttle and Hunter have
booted by this time and managed to
establish contact with each other
because of the fact that they were still
in a reduced light speed region they
could not use Fusion drives because
within such a region they would put out
too little power
the shuttle and the ship however were
both equipped with anti-matter drives
designed specifically for use within
reduced light speed regions the specific
Human Society who built the ship and the
shuttle had put great effort into
developing such Technologies the reason
was not simply in case one of their
vessels encountered reduced light speed
conditions but because they were in fact
planning ahead just in case their
specific world would have to one day
enter into a black domain to hide itself
from potential exposure in the dark
Forest it took about a half an hour for
the anti-matter system to activate the
shuttle and the ship began decelerating
over the course of the next 20 minutes
they drop out of light speed the
hypergravity of the process forcefully
presses shangzin and yifan into their
seats they can see planet blue is now no
longer blue but instead purple the stars
in the sky appeared as lions Crossing in
space
this was due to the fact that because of
the rupturing of the death lines the
dx3906 system was now a black domain
they saw stars as if they were seeing
them from inside a black hole all the
stars in space had turned into lines of
light shungxin was actually familiar
with such a site she had seen plenty of
long exposure photographs taken of the
Starry Sky from Earth due to Earth's
rotation the stars and pictures all
became concentric arcs of approximately
the same length but now the Stars she
saw were segments of different links and
aligned Every Which Way the longest few
lines in fact took up almost a third of
the sky these lines crossed each other
at different angles and made space
appear far more confusing and chaotic
than before
the dx3906 star system was now cut off
from the rest of the universe
as far as they knew they could never
leave it
but there was still the question of what
now waited on the planet
a change in the sun's radiation over
time had caused the vegetation of the
world to adapt this resulted in the
color change of the world when viewed
from space Xiang Xin and yifan could
detect that the oxygen concentration of
the planet was considerably higher than
it had been the last time they had
stepped foot on the world the
geographical structure of the planet had
also significantly changed since they
had last been there
guanyifan and shungxin surveyed the
landscape of the planet and though it
was full of life there was no sign of
human life no trace of tianming or his
vessel Hunter which was still in orbit
above planet purple had an exceptionally
powerful computer after completing its
scans it confirmed that there were no
humans on the planet whatsoever
shungxin initially believes that maybe
several tens of thousands of years have
passed but she grossly underestimated by
taking Rock samples taken from the
planet and measuring their atomic Decay
they determined the actual length of
time that had gone by average atomic
Decay dating results error range 0.4
percent Stellar time periods lapsed
6177 906 Earth years collapsed 18
million nine hundred and three thousand
seven hundred and twenty nine
they knew then that both Tian Ming and
AA had been dead for millions of years
however remembers what luogi had done
earlier in the novel when the solar
system was attacked with the Dual Vector
foil leading to a dimension strike
causing the collapse of Earth's solar
system into two Dimensions luoji who
during the crisis era saved Mankind from
destruction at the hands of the Alien
Invaders the trisolarins attempted to
preserve some of Humanity's history on
the world Pluto by carving into stone he
believed more so than any method that
this was the most permanent
commands Hunter to scan at a depth range
between 20 and 30 meters Hunter's AI was
capable of recognizing language an hour
later it brought back fragments of Words
which had been carved into an enormous
Bedrock now buried 30 meters Beneath the
Planet
we lived a happy life together we give
you a little survive the collapse inside
go to the new
before the death lines had ruptured AA
said that Tian Ming had a gift for Shang
Xin that was the gift being referenced
here it was the gift of an entire
universe
part 3 Universe 647
guanyifan and shangzin eventually
discover the door the gift left by Tian
Ming it had been left there for more
than 18 million years to call it just a
door would be inaccurate it was almost
sentient it remembered that in the
beginning it had been placed next to the
carved Rock containing the text in the
beginning it had also had a metal frame
but that had eroded millions of years
ago it itself had no fear of erosion
because it existed outside of time when
it detected the presence of humans on
the surface of the world it Rose to the
surface while doing so it made no
interaction with the crust it moved
through the world like a ghost it
immediately confirmed that guanyifan and
shungxin were the two humans that it had
been expecting
something strange interrupted their
meditation a rectangle limbed by faint
lines of light about a man's height
hovered over the clearing like the dash
section lines marked out by dragging a
mouse
it moved through air but did not go far
before returning to its original
position it was possible that it had
been there all along but the outline was
so faint and thin that it was invisible
during daytime
whether it was made by a force field or
actual substance there was no doubt it
was the creation of intelligence
after walking through the door Chang are
immersed in primordial darkness and also
experience the sense of being in a Time
vacuum the same as when they encountered
the ruptured deadlines
for a moment time does not exist
Darkness disappeared time began there is
no appropriate expression in human
language to express the moment at the
start of time to say that time begin
after they entered the door would be
wrong because after required time there
was no time here and thus no before or
after the time after they entered could
have been shorter than a billion
billionth of a second or longer than a
billion billion years
the miniature universe beyond the door
was a completely enclosed World in which
the end was also the beginning
when you walk all the way to its Edge
you simply return to where you started
there was a sun and a blue sky an
unplanted field with black soil a large
white house and Tiny robots attending it
all from the house a woman walks out
shangzin recognizes her immediately so
fun so fun had been the Avatar through
which the trisilarans had spoke to
humanity through during the deterrence
era she had also been Humanity's cruel
dictator following the fall of that era
but this so fun was somehow different so
fun had only been a puppet of the
trisolarins this version served another
purpose
she was the manager of this universe
which was called Universe 647 she was
essentially placed there by Tian Ming to
serve guanyifan and shangzin the war
between trisolaris and humankind was
quite literally ancient history it had
ended millions of years ago this entire
miniature Universe had been constructed
with trisolaran technology they learned
from so fun that time moves much slower
in the miniature Universe than in the
greater Universe Tian Ming believed that
the great Universe was headed for
collapse essentially the Big Crunch
following the crunch a new Big Bang this
would create a new universe a new
identic age a universe possessing 10
Dimensions not degraded by life
Tian Ming had hoped that Shang Xin and
guani than could wait within the
miniature Universe until the birth of
the new greater Universe it was
calculated that after a span of about 10
years in the miniature Universe the
greater Universe would reach its end
the miniature Universe was not actually
on planet blue only its entrance was it
was truly outside the greater Universe
fully independent as time goes by within
the miniature Universe Shang Xin and
guanyi fan learn more and more about its
nature but much of It is
incomprehensible to them they don't
understand how a complete ecological
cycle could function in such a small
sealed place what exactly was the Sun
and where did the Heat of the miniature
Universe go given that it was a closed
system they also learned that the
miniature Universe cannot communicate
with the greater universe but it was
possible for the mini Universe to
receive broadcast from the greater
Universe this was possible because all
the universes were in fact bubbles above
a super membrane this was something that
the trisolarins had discovered there
were other great universes beyond our
own some possessing intelligent life
great universes had enough enough energy
to propagate information across the
super membrane this required an
astronomical amount of energy equivalent
to the total amount of energy within an
entire galaxy
as a matter of fact the monitoring
systems in Universe 647 often received
messages from other great universes on
the super membrane some were natural
phenomenon some were messages from
intelligent beings that could not be
decoded but they had never received any
messages from the particular great
Universe they had come from
after more than a year inside the
miniature Universe it finally happens
they receive a message from their own
Universe it is a broadcast in countless
languages all the languages of the great
races throughout the Universe who made
their Mark among them included the
languages of the trisolarins and of the
Earth for shangzin and guanyifan the
Earth's languages being presented
confirmed that Humanity had endured in
the cosmos but the content of the
broadcast itself brought a grave message
from a group of beings known as the
returners
a notice from the returners the total
mass of our universe has decreased to
below the critical threshold
the universe will turn from being closed
to open and die a slow death in
Perpetual expansion all lives and all
memories will also die please return the
mass you have taken away and send only
memories to the new universe a miniature
Universe could not exist without first
taking matter from the greater universe
the message was clear Universe 647 was
one of who knows how many miniature
universes constructed by Humanity the
trisolarians and countless others each
one containing matters stolen from the
greater Universe without the return of
that matter the universe could not reset
to its sedinic age
In Perpetual expansion all the galaxies
would move farther and farther away from
each other until none were visible from
any other by then standing at any point
in the universe all one would see was
darkness in every direction the Stars
would go out one by one and all
celestial bodies would turn into thin
dust clouds coldness and darkness would
Reign Over All and the universe would
become a vast empty tomb all
civilizations and all memories would be
buried in that endless tomb for eternity
death would be eternal in order to save
the universe the matter locked up in all
of the many universes would need to be
brought back this however means that all
the refugees fleeing the destruction of
the crunch would have to return to the
greater universe as well shanzin and
guani fan make their decision they will
dismantle the mini universe and return
to the greater universe
within the miniature Universe they leave
a quantum computer containing the entire
memory of trisolaris and the Earth and a
tiny sphere containing a fully sealed
ecological system with a tiny light
emitter
as long as it remained there Universe
647 would not be a lifeless empty and
Dark World entering their fusion-powered
vessel they leave Universe 647 forever
into the main Universe which has
advanced 10 billion years Planet blue no
longer existed the star dx3906 had long
ago vanished it was a possibility though
they could not say for certain that the
great Universe would no longer even be
three-dimensional once they entered it
it was within their capabilities to move
the entrance to the mini Universe
elsewhere once they exited they would
appear somewhere else in the greater
Universe what exactly they might
encounter they did not know
this is where deaths end concludes the
story is continued however in the
spin-off novel which was not written by
shishan Lu but instead by Basha titled
Redemption of time
an interesting thing that lucision does
at the end of this novel is set up how
terrible and sad the idea of the
universe endlessly expanding in darkness
would be if they could not repair it but
the fact is the continued expansion of
the universe is one of the main
currently accepted theories for what may
happen in real life
scientists realized a while ago that the
Big Crunch was most likely not possible
the universe is expanding due to a
mysterious Force known as dark energy
Dark Energy makes up about 70 percent of
the universe and we really don't know
what it is but we do know that it is
causing the expansion of the universe
and we also know that the expansion is
not stopping it is in fact accelerating
scientists say that eventually every
particle in the universe will be
perfectly spaced out because of this
gravity would have no effect there would
be no light no movement just endless
silence and darkness
the fact that this seems to be the
reality for the future of the cosmos
makes this ending all the more
existential the inhabitants of the
three-body problem Universe have a way
to save themselves we do not
I think that the ending of death's end
also presents an environmentalist
metaphor the universe is Earth those who
have selfishly taken pieces of it and
hoarded them away are ensuring its
destruction it is up to everyone to come
together make sacrifices and return what
they have taken so that everything is
ultimately not destroyed
many of the themes of this series are
intriguing and terrifying as we've
discussed here but there are also
certain things about this series that
just ring true what if we could become
so Advanced that we start doing to the
universe what we are doing to the Earth
destroying it with war with the careless
usage of Technology draining its
resources until nothing functions as it
should the metaphor here is clear people
often ask me what exactly it is that I
love so much about this series I love it
because it does exactly what science
fiction should do it takes a real thing
like the fear of the outside or the
human capacity for self-destruction and
it shines a new light on it what would
all of these very real things be like in
the context of a universe full of
hostile aliens a universe with weapons
that break the universe itself and
technology that leaves ruptures in
space-time this is a Trilogy that kept
me glued to the page all the way to the
Inn because I just kept asking what's
the next stage what other potential
ominous questions about the universe are
going to be explored next if a writer
can do that then I think that is very
effective writing even though we've
gotten to the end of the book there are
still more aspects of this series to
explore and I will continue to explore
those aspects and videos in the future
as well as exploring the spin-off novel
Redemption of time thank you guys so
much for watching make sure you like And
subscribe for more Quinn's ideas
also check out our patreon as it is the
best way to support this channel thanks
so much it is now time for patreon
questions first question from Donovan
Carr g'day Quinn keep up the great work
we know that the trisolarin fleet
changed Direction once the gravitational
wave transmitter was activated and
determined that both trisolaris and
Earth were doomed due to dark force
Theory why wouldn't trisolaris agree to
work with Humanity to fight slash defend
against a common slash unknown enemy or
pool resources to work toward a common
goal such as colonizing a stable
planetary system together seems like
such a waste of resources and
potentially dooming both species instead
of enforced collaboration enhancing
their survival rate anime Mine by Barry
b long year comes to mind in this regard
okay so when answering this question we
have to look at the themes of this
particular series and one of the biggest
themes is paranoia and I think that's
one of the biggest things too that would
have stopped something like that from
working I don't think Humanity could
have ever really trusted trisilaris
at least not at that point in time I
think it would have been too early for
these two civilizations to have a
functioning collaboration of any kind
that would have lasted long term at this
point in their existence I think it's
simply too early and also it just does
not fit the themes of the book if this
was a different kind of story then maybe
that's something that could have
potentially been explored
I think this is a good time to point out
and this is true with almost every book
that you will ever read sometimes even
with speculative science fiction what
happens is not necessarily what would
happen in real life The Narrative
unfoldings instead reflect and emphasize
something that the author is trying to
say specifically they could want to
explore some kind of statement about the
human condition or in some cases explore
a specific emotion when it comes to
narrative structures even in stories
that are mostly meant to be viewed
realistically sometimes the theme has to
take precedent
the next question is from John Stanton
have you watched Person of Interest
Westworld and the periphery I don't even
know if sci-fi fans even know that all
three shows by Nolan tell the story of
the AI God that saves Humanity from
destruction very interesting so to
answer your question I have not watched
Person of Interest I have not watched
the periphery I have watched season one
of Westworld I did not consume any of
the other seasons of Westworld
unfortunately it's not that I had
anything particularly against the show I
thought that season one of Westworld
could have been six episodes and I felt
like for me as of an avid science
fiction fan that the show wasn't
offering me anything that I hadn't seen
before in a more interesting form and
that's an experience that I often have
watching science fiction movies and
watching science fiction television
shows because books are so much more
Vivid and often so much more detailed
that's nothing against that show or
against these other two shows I might
give them a try in the future but at
this time I have not seen them but that
concept of the AI God that saves
Humanity from destruction is an
interesting concept and it reminds me of
a kind of a reversal just hearing the
concept reminds me of a kind of reversal
of the idea of the technological
singularity which is this idea of when
AI surpasses humans and bad things are
implied to happen from that point on
this concept by the sound of it seems
like the opposite AI rising up and
saving Humanity from itself kind of
thanks for the incredible content you
put out what are your feelings on the
cyberpunk sub genre ever plan to tackle
any of the cyberpunk greats like
Neuromancer snow crash and altered
carbon the like I've enjoyed some of
these as much as dune and would really
dig to see them get the Quinn treatment
well first of all thank you for calling
cyberpunk a sub-genre because I've seen
people refer to cyberpunk as a genre and
I don't really see it as a genre because
the only substantive difference from
cyberpunk and regular science fiction is
purely aesthetic in my opinion and it
can be a pretty subtle aesthetic shift
honestly I think there's a little bit
debate about some things whether they
are cyberpunk and not cyberpunk anyway
to answer your question yes I do plan on
covering gibbons's Neuromancer at some
point in the future specifically alright
guys that's it for the questions in this
video thanks so much for watching
[Music]
foreign